when everybody's special no one is so
after a couple of little teasers mostly
just sort of showing off jacked a couple
of jokes we get a proper trailer for The
Incredibles - which is a movie I know a
lot of people are really looking forward
for and this is a movie that I left it
off my most anticipated movies of 2018
lists not because I think it'll be bad
but I'm I'm kind of skeptical The
Incredibles doesn't need a sequel it did
exactly what it needed to do now that
doesn't mean anything there are plenty
of movies that didn't need sequels and
still got pretty good ones or even great
ones in some cases so that's not an
automatic knock against it but I for one
wasn't aching for a new Incredibles
movie as much as I love the original and
having seen this trailer I'm a little
bit nervous if I'm gonna be honest and I
know that it's going to result in a
whole bunch of people because everybody
loves Pixar and it's somehow against the
law to question them but and so many
people are gonna tell me stop being a
buzzkill wait for the movie that did
that look I'm gonna tell you what I
thought of the thing you what I saw it
made me nervous and there's stuff that
looks good there's stuff that looks fine
the stuff that looks great you know
we've got all this cast packed it was
great hearing these voices I like that
it starts right off with the Underminer
cuz honestly that seemed kind of fun and
it looks like they're actually gonna do
some fun things with that I'm sure it's
just the opening action beat but still
that works well they've still got the
family dynamic everybody's got good
chemistry going the animation style is
good the little bits of actually it
looked great and the modes back all of
these are good things where my concerns
are coming in largely has to do with the
whole thing of Bob having to stay home
with the kids and watch Jack act in
particular while Helen goes off and
does all the superheroing now on the one
hand part of me likes that because I
like the idea of Helen getting you know
to be more of a firm central hero than
she was last time not unless she really
got the short shrift last time I don't
want to apply that but I'd like her to
get a little more time in the Sun that
said at least what is presented in this
trailer it doesn't look like we're
actually gonna get that what it looks
like is she leaves and now we focus on
Bob not being fully comfortable a
probably being at home at all and not
being in on the action and then be
taking Derick the kids on his own and
there's a couple things that that this
concerns me about the first is is that I
fear that for Bob specifically it's too
close to his arc in the first movie
because in the first movie you know he
was all anxious and put off because he
couldn't you know superhero at all and
now you know he was stuck in that job
that was unfulfilled and now he's gonna
be put off because his wife is off doing
it and instead of being at a job he's
now at home so I mean I'd like to think
he likes being at home more than he
liked being at that job but the scenario
and the kinds of resentment and strain
that's kind of put on and that that's
potentially gonna wring a lot of the
same bells that the first one did in
terms of him specifically as a character
in his journey and that's gonna matter
if he is the main central focus again I
and I mean you know the previous movie
was about the families all I expect this
one will be too but it was mostly about
Bob and if this is also that well then
it feels repeating and another thing is
is that what comes with this is oh we're
doing mr. mom again for the who knows
how many hundredth time that this sort
of thing has been done in pop culture
look at the dad who didn't expect to be
home alone watching the kid try and why
she kid and watch how unprepared he is
isn't that wacky men don't take care of
babies and yes there's the superhero and
the superpowers aspect that puts a
little twist on it yes I do understand
this is a period piece in it at that
time it actually would be severely out
of his comfort zone and against the
societal norms of the time way more than
it would be the case today but even with
my understanding all that that's still a
premise and a and a starting foundation
for drama and stress and story that I
feel like I this feels very tired this
doesn't feel like the next incredible
story that demanded to be told this
feels like what they came up with when
somebody sat down and said you know we
really ought to get around to making an
Incredibles movie and Brad Bird you kind
of owe us one because that whole World
of Tomorrow thing fell apart so
spectacularly
and no I'm not saying oh it's gonna suck
it'll probably be fine
at worst it'll be fine it could even be
great I hope it is I'm probably gonna
end up seeing it I'm just seeing things
that for me are causes for concern there
are things that I see them and then I
think boy if that means what I think it
means that's gonna be something that I
potentially might not like and that's
just the impression that I'm left with
then and it's not a bad trailer it's a
perfectly fine trailer but what it shows
me and what it lays out is stuff that
makes me nervous for this movie in terms
of what it's going to deliver whether
it's gonna feel like it's truly a new
chapter for this family or whether it
feels like it's retreading the last one
and just mining the best that it can
from it and again that doesn't
necessarily have to be a bad thing I
mean that's largely what finding dory
wasn't finding Dory was pretty good but
at the same time you know it does kind
of make me think boy you could have put
all the effort that went into this
you know the anime
there's Brad Bird everybody else and you
know do something new but we'll see and
there's plenty of time you know and and
you know I think if I were to say
something that would give me some I
think more solid foundation for me to be
optimistic would be if we get later
trailers and each of them focuses on one
of the other family members about as
much as this one focuses on Bob and then
that might tell me oh it's not gonna be
the central focus on him for most of the
movie again like it was last time they
just did that for this trailer cuz he
was little leave here last time and now
here's one focusing on violet and here's
one focus like if I can get a sense that
everybody's gonna be equal even more
equal billing than they were last time
that would be that would waylay some of
my fears because right now I'm concerned
that I'm not going to particularly care
for or I'm gonna feel like Bob's
Ark is repetitive and something I've
seen done before so now it's a question
of how much of the film is that and
that's what I don't really know and
again even the stuff that I'm skeptical
about maybe it'll work I'm just telling
you what I thought I've been feeling I'm
gonna get torn apart for this one maybe
not we'll see in any case The
Incredibles - the I guess it was the
Olympics teaser is what they officially
called it what were your thoughts on it
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it do all
that stuff think about supporting me on
patreon follow me on Twitter I got a
podcast there's links for all that stuff
down in the description so until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]